- [Jordan] In the
early Vayner days,
I don't know if this
happened you guys but
one of the objections
that we get all the time is,
you know, we have people who
do this or our kids do this or
we've got people
internally who do this.
- I tell them that there's a
big difference between
the way I play basketball and
the way LeBron James
plays basketball.
- [Jordan] Uh-huh.
- There's no accident that
L is the best you've got.
- [Jordan] Right.
- You just tell them right to
their fucking face that we're
better at it.
- [Jordan] Yeah, yeah.
- And if they say well we don't
value the difference between our
B player and your A player then
you say Mazel Tov and you go
into the building.
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- Don't dwell on
that conversation.
Tell 'em right to their face
what you believe and move on.
- [Jordan] Cool.
- I mean it's that basic.
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- What are you gonna try
to convince the unsellable?
- [Jordan] Right.
- I don't give a fuck
what your excuse is.
It's the excuse and I'm leaving.
- [Jordan] Right.
That's a good point.
Did you get that--
- Constantly!
And I was the guy.
- [Jordan] I would say--
- I was the fucking
guy and I got it.
And I said, "Great,
I'll see you in 2015."
- [Jordan] Yeah. Totally.
- And so, the companies that
passed on paying
me $5,000 a month,--
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- came in four years later
paying me $80,000 a month.
- [Jordan] That's awesome.
- They fucked up.
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- And I love it.
- 'Cause they deserve it.
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- But I didn't dwell on it
or waste my time
building my business.
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- Get over it, move on
and go to the next person.
- [Jordan] Yes.
- There's unlimited people
you can actually get to.
- [Jordan] And we think that
space has so much opportunity.
- Next.
- [Jordan] So the next one,--
- You need to really
nail that one in your brain.
- [Jordan] Uh-huh.
- It would be the best thing
that happens in your business.
- [Jordan] Awesome.
- Sitting in your bed crying
about the girl that didn't want
to go out with you for a year is
not gonna let you
find the next girl.
- [Jordan] Yeah, agreed.
- Next.
- [Jordan] Agreed.
So, one of the things that
we're doing as an agency,
you know, I think similar to you
guys is we have things that we
want to do on the side.
We're thinking
about doing commerce,
we have an
information newsletter,
that's what we're doing.
- Get big enough that the
distractions are worthwhile,--
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- but don't kill the mothership.
- [Jordan] So that was
kind of the question, right?
'Cause I've been part of
three other startups on my own
previous career and--
- Any successful ones?
- [Jordan] Vault.com, they
eventually got acquired,--
- But you were never
sitting at the top?
- [Jordan] No, no, no.
- Got it.
You were a part
of the journey. Respect.
- [Jordan] But always at
Day 1 or employee 30.
- Cool. So you got to see a lot.
Yeah.
- [Jordan] I helped build
three other companies.
- Yep.
- [Jordan] A part of that and
that's been a really nice.
- Good for you.
Good for you.
- [Jordan] And I feel
good about that.
I used to call those, when those
entrepreneurs would go off
into those things I'd call
them corporate distractions.
- Yes.
- [Jordan] Now I want to do it.
I want to do these other things.
- When you're an entrepreneur,
you have a wavering eye.
- [Jordan] Yeah, totally.
- You're unfaithful.
That skirt looks cute.
- [Jordan] Right. (laughs)
- I get it.
I've never, you know, when
it comes to entrepreneurship,
I'm playing the field hard.
- [Jordan] Mhmmm.
- I'm super in love
with Vayner but I'm like,
who's that?
- [Jordan] Right.
- And that happens
to me every day.
I'm a scum bucket when it
comes to entrepreneurship and
I would tell you
that you can go and
have a little more fun once
you've got a little bit of an
established situation so I would
say that be very careful
of not doing it too early.
- [Jordan] Right.
- And realize, you know, there's
something I said the other day,
like, eat shit for 24 months and
then eat caviar
the rest of your life.
- [Jordan] Yep.
- It's not that exact but that's
how I think about it here.
Build something that gives you,
build something and then when
it's got enough
strength, go and do it.
The reason there was a big gap
in me putting out content was
I needed 2011, '12 and
'13 to build Vayner.
That allowed me then to
get back in to content,
do the PureWow deal, you know?
- [Jordan] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I used to watch
you on Revision3.
So I used to run video at Good
Magazine and back in the day.
- Yeah.
- [Jordan] You know, in early
YouTube days were so amazing
because if the video was good
and the content was good and
there was audience
for it, you know,
hundreds of
thousands of views--
- Yep.
- [Jordan] was super easy.
So we used to sit
there and watch,
it was Revision3, right?
- Yeah.
- [Jordan] Tekzilla and
we'd sit there and be like,
"Who is this guy
talking about wine
"in New Jersey with the Jets?"
You know?
It was amazing and so...
- It seems so
insane, right, it was so,
everything was tech.
- [Jordan] Right.
- So there was this
like, you said it perfectly.
New Jersey, wine and Jets.
- [Jordan] What does this guy
spitting wine into a bucket for
20 minutes on, you know?
The days of Wine Library TV
that was amazing.
- Thank you.
- [Jordan] And you know finally,
I just really
wanted to thank you.
I said in my note, you know,
I had this serious
kind of health issue.
That's how all this was born.
- Yep.
- [Jordan] And I got well through
this like total fluke situation.
While that was all happening, it
was tremendous rebuilding period
around the time
you were doing
"Jab, Jab, Jab Right Hook" and
so I just also wanted
to also thank you
because all of the energy that
you were pouring out on those
videos was just like my
inspiration every day to keep
doing what I was doing and you
know and I was literally like
left for dead by mainstream
doctors and it was like a fluke
encounter with someone who
lead to these amazing guys
specializing in Crohn's and
colitis as well as pediatric
mitochondrial disorders that got
me on to this really unique path
of wellness that
took like a year.
So would just sit on my
treadmill as part of my PT and
watch these GaryVee
videos all day long.
So I just wanted to also,--
- It's super hard to
consume that 'cause
it just means so much to me.
I don't know what to say
but thank you so much.
- [Jordan] No, thank you.
- We live in such
an amazing time.
If I was born 30, 40 years
earlier I just would've been
really well-liked
successful businessman
in some neighborhood.
- [Jordan] Right.
- We're just so lucky to be
living this time where like,
listen man, I don't know what
it's gonna feel like when I buy
the Jets but I'm really gonna
struggle to think it feels any
better than the way my
heart feels right now.
- [Jordan] Nice, thank you.
- I really mean that.
- [Jordan] I appreciate that, yeah.
- Another human being,
think about that.
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- And I feel like I'm
just getting started.
So, like, it's pretty cool.
Thank you very much for that.
- [Jordan] Thank you so
much for the time.
Last thing,--
- Yeah?
- [Jordan] on this side
thing that we're working on,
if we get a little more baked
would it be okay if
I reached out in--
- 100%.
- [Jordan] four or five months.
- You made me feel
really good right now.
You bought
yourself some leverage.
Yeah, yes.
- [Jordan] That would be great.
- Cool.
- [Jordan] Can I get a selfie?
- Yeah, of course.
- [Jordan] Sweet. Thank you.
Can I do it with all
the crap in there?
- Yeah, of course.
Awesome.
- Awesome.
Thank you so much for your time.
'Preciate it. Thank you
for everything you do.
- That was very kind.
- [Jordan] I really appreciate it.
- [Gary] So happy it
worked out for you, man.
- [Jordan] Thank you, I am one--
- [Gary] Yes, you're
a happier than I am.
- [Jordan] I am one lucky guy.
- That gratitude,
brother, drive with that.
Do not let any, when I gave
you that first answer to that
question now, that should be a
foregone conclusion for you.
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- Comparatively.
Never, you know
this is what happens,
with life threatening
events, you forget.
- [Jordan] Totally.
- It's like getting, it's
like when the cop car goes,
and then when it drives by
you, you get and then you
start driving fast again.
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- People don't
realize this, you do.
I understand it, thank
God I've never had it.
- [Jordan] Right.
- People forget.
- Do not forget.
- [Jordan] This is a video
game for me now.
- But, you know what?
Don't say it, live it.
- [Jordan] Right.
- Losing that client,
somebody saying no.
Means nothing.
- [Jordan] Right.
Agreed.
- [Gary] Real pleasure.
- [Jordan] Thanks, dude.
- [Gary] Take care.
- [Jordan] Appreciate it.
Thank you.
- [Gary] Stay well.
- [Jordan] Thanks, DRock.
Bye guys.
- [Gary] Bye-bye.